احداث متسارعه يشهدها السودان في رابع
ايام الاشتباكات الداميه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع لكن الرؤيه النهائيه بشان
الطرف العسكري الذي سيبسط سيطرته على
الارض لم تتضح حتى هذه اللحظه تعددت
الروايات بين الاطراف المتنازعه والمتضرر
واحد الشعب السوداني الذي عان وما زال من
هذه الصراعات معدلات القتل والاصابات
تتزايد بوتيره متفاقمه والعديد من
المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه فبعضها ضربت
بالقذائف والبعض الاخر انقطعت عنه
الكهرباء ولا يجد للامدادات الطبيه سبيله
اذا استمر القتال سيكون هناك المزيد من
الضحايا الارقام التي حصلت عليها لم يتم
تاكيدها نحن نعتمد على معلومات من الاطباء
السودانيين ومن المستشفيات حتى الان قتل
ما لا يقل عن 185 شخصا واصي اكثر من 1800
شخص بمن فيهم مدنيون وعناصر الجيش تحرك
صعب يواجه السكان في ظل القصف الجوي
والاشتباكات العنيفه على الارض
واماكن متفرقه احتجز فيها السودانيون منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات ومنها الجامعات غير
المجهزه لحال كهذه والعديد من هؤلاء
المحتجزين حاولوا الخروج للعوده الى
منازلهم اثناء هدنه وقف اطلاق النار التي
دعت اليها بعثه الامم المتحده الا ان
الاطراف المتصارعه لم تلتزم بها رغم
التعهدات باحترامها
احنا حوالي 88
نفر مننا عشرين عامل فيهم كبار السن
وفي حوالي خمسه طالبات المعارك في السودان
احدثت نكسه غذائيه بسبب صعوبه التنقل
وارتفاع الاسعار وسط تعليق العشرات من
برامج المساعدات الانسانيه بعد ان نهبت
الامدادات ودمرت
لا يمكنني اعطائك اي ارقام محدده حول قيمه
الممتلكات المسروقه او الامدادات المنهوبه
او حتى المساعدات التي دمرت بسبب القتال
كما قلت في وقت سابق في هذه الظروف لا
يمكن ان يحدث اي توصيل للمساعدات بشكل
اساسي تمديد وقلق اماميان واطراف اقليميه
ودوليه تقف على خط الازمه التي اتساحت
الثالثه اكبر بلد افريقي الا ان تلك
المساعي والمحاولات المتعدده لم تجد اذانا
صاغيه حتى الان سلطان العيبان العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات